[Music]
Sonne 48 seconds of logos look it's a
metaphor for what this movie did to the
franchise because i get the peter's dad
had to leave but he doesn't have to be a
total dick about it nothing to see here
just washing some fresh blood off my
hands also what did this guy do to the
pilot rip a distraught assassin leaves
loaded gun where his victims could
easily find it
this bathroom walks from the outside we
interrupt this movie to bring you the
poor man's Bourne Identity good thing
that dead pilot was holding the plane
steady this whole time ah the snakes on
a plane school of bad guy removal seven
minutes in children are starting to ask
their parents why spider-man isn't in
the movie how did he get up that high
did he jump out of a plane
physics where's Spidey hiding that radio
no one told Paul Giamatti this wasn't a
cartoon
[Music]
and that by standards allowed explosives
thanks for the exposition computer
you're not a nobody you're somebody hey
when you're done boosting this guy's
self-esteem there's still a plutonium
filled truck barreling through New York
thanks again computer we interrupt this
movie to bring you the Blues Brothers
spider-sense where was Spidey hiding
that cell phone in a skin-tight suit
there's only one place he could be
stashing his stuff you don't want to
know where it is seven years after super
bad emma stone is still graduating from
high school ghost dad she looks pretty
surprised to win valedictorian for
someone wearing a scarf that says
valedictorian guess that guy got held
back like two three 20 years oh cool
spider-man just came to our graduate uh
it's just beautiful
way to make it all about YouTube
probably something boring about
responsibility traffic jam of anything
this photo was taken right before the
cameraman died later Thank You ghost dad
part two the ghosting and you've clearly
broken that promise between now and the
last movie did he just fight a chicken
did he just fight a fish you're not
gonna give him the discount double check
spider stalking doesn't he wear masks
I'll just stash this briefcase full of
important information here until the
plot requires me to open it let's see we
got coffee made red stuff ooh an electro
cake you like that Spidey this is
getting dangerously close to slash
pictures in case we didn't have enough
supplies going already and may is
becoming a nurse for some reason so
purple Aunt May makes Peter and all that
a sandwich for breakfast
[Music]
exposition hologram those were designed
by me what a coincidence
max I'm Gwen what a coincidence
it was fun he saved me everybody gets
one thirty minutes in and we're still
introducing main characters this is not
how I always imagined I'd be impaled to
my own glider sixteenth birthday
you sent me scotch sounds like a pretty
cool dad to me retroviral hyperplasia
aka they're trying to make the Green
Goblin into a realistic character
disease guess that lucrative Bing
sponsorship from the first movie didn't
pay off
Jay jonah Jameson does not appear in
this movie this just in main character
needs to be brought up to speed on the
other characters pot lines sports at
11:00 can we shut down a Power on sector
32 please Oscorp doesn't have 24-hour
maintenance there's your problem right
there the thing is all unplugged hey
boss should we put a lid on these tanks
now what's the worst that could happen
Electric dentistry so he gets
electrocuted bit by electric eels
electrocuted again and blown up how does
this just not kill him someone got paid
to write this what is he doing what a
coincidence
just one spiderman woman we don't know
pretty sure the bull gentle like a babes
makes him a dude dude I guess this is
one of those discs out morgg's that
leaves dead bodies out in the open with
the crematorium running
Peter Parker is addictive traffic yep
that'll do electro sets off all of these
car alarms because he is electric uh yes
the suburban street that leads directly
to Times Square just once a day
sometimes
Peter studied at the Twilight school of
romance Oxford and it's between means
other kid him there's this oral exam
that we've just do and he's like a
freshman in college but he's 14 cut is
everyone in this movie a science genius
this random camera guy has a live feed
to every video screen in Times Square
sure just opened fired the guy because
he's blue and wearing a hoodie run you
idiots it's totally not your birthday
anymore dude you fell into that tank the
night before I like you're on the
screenwriters are making up his powers
as they go Mamma Mia
not the Jersey Boys oh yes really
how many times can fate tell you it's a
bad idea for you two to be together
Phillip Phillips that completely
unrelated battle really got Peter
thinking about his dead parents to
question marks don't get better Google
results you know it's way easier to hang
framed photos if you use a nail this
wall of craziness we just watched and
build won't factor into the rest of the
movie at all ah oh so that's how you
turn this desk on suppose science genius
has to learn about batteries from
YouTube this guy definitely bought views
on his video he only has two subscribers
and look at that like ratio total fraud
it's 14 years of research and nothing to
show for it except maybe this oh look
the five boroughs school budget past I
mean to find I need his blood here goes
Kurtzman and Orci with the whole magic
blood thing again didn't you guys get
that out of your system when you were
ruining Star Trek you took his picture
you know him
that's not how pictures work what a
coincidence
the maintenance closet is the most
cliched hiding place ever this is the
most cliche hiding place you could have
chosen oh sin retracted yeah you ghost
dad Wednesday's me what a coincidence
yeah man these Oscorp elevators are
convenient places for characters they
wouldn't normally meet to run into each
other good thing Oscorp had a prison so
for a being of pure electricity ready to
go in case whenever showed up
I'm docked to cuff this stereotypical
German scientist Dr Who I
how could he know that's the first time
you've ever said it maybe everyone has a
part of themselves they hide even from
the people they love it's funny cuz you
sound just like him
underage drinking arrest him spider-man
if our blood isn't compatible you could
die I'm already died yeah in like 40
years your blood can't make me die more
but it could do something more if only
one of us had access to some kind of
massive science corporation to look into
it sorry well that was a useful meeting
Kramer entrance baby signs point to
Oxford yeah what's the one thing break a
neck I mean break a leg
no not the wall of craziness so his dad
had to open up his calculator every time
he took the subway and why go through
the trouble to hide them
they look like subway tokens go home
Felicia bye Felicia
there may be another way to get what
you're looking for I overheard what a
coincidence
oh I liked her said different lines the
first time we saw this beach Oh
looks to me like you're halfway in the
ground already really cuz it looks like
he's got a little boo-boo to me let him
go man
I'm sure he won't do anything crazy if
neo shows up looking for the Train man
I'm out so Peters dad uploaded this
confessional video to a secret subway
station laboratory just in case someone
eventually broke his calculator to find
the secret subway tokens and investigate
got it design for the grid and Harry
absorbed all of Max's history and
motivations from that 10-second video he
saw ten minutes ago ad dematerialization
to electro sloppy list of powers add dr.
Manhattan to electro sloppy list of
powers add creating boxer briefs to
electors it didn't work out and whose
fault was that when Stacy moves to
England with an hours of finding out she
got the scholarship remember me nope
it's the first time these two characters
have met face to face in the entire
movie where did he get that fabulous
leather outfit so he's no longer a
physical being where do his clothes go
this Harry is the Oscorp Hall of
spin-offs do it
- not in the gun armed security lockdown
protocol involves opening the door to
military-grade hardware good thing the
green Goblin's suit was already sized
for a five foot nothing teenager
vandalism England both of us with great
power comes great responsibility unless
the girl you're porking moves to England
Wednesday CJ's supervision no he hasn't
got to that YouTube video yet coming
with you I've seen the grid specs and I
know how to reset the entire system what
a coincidence
he's the only one who saw you in the
first place which makes your sudden
hatred of him make absolutely zero sense
what kind of power plant has a clock
tower
[Music]
I hate this song that makes all of us I
know they say is soot is rubberized but
even so that is a lot of electricity to
absorb with no consequences can this
wait kind of in the middle of a fight
with my nemesis here ghost dad three
ghosts dad takes New York when stacey
has super hearing this movie still isn't
over yet spider venom gives you meth
mouth
Peter oh now he gets it go green goblin
subscribes to the Joker's supervillain
school of taking things literally
obvious metaphor is obvious not to be
insensitive but after a fall like that
there's no way that's a closed head
wound on the bright side a 14-year old
boy just got a scholarship to Oxford yay
morning as the seasons change montage
from Twilight you're looking better it
comes and goes
how convenient so it's been five months
since Gwen Stacy died and she was taking
early summer classes then climate change
has hit New York in a big way spider guy
and he's disappeared seems like
everybody really needs him hold on to
hope where does this footage come from
there was no camera at this graduation
now shoot him now
mom brings her kid downtown to go watch
a massive firefight tobey maguire
the bravest kid I've ever seen
now shoot him now run you idiots this
was such a great shot in the trailer I
can't wait to see what comes next
it's over well you do then
[Music]
well that was weird
click on the link above to check out the
honest trailer for the amazing
spider-man 2 from cinemasins and as
always subscribe